he predicts that Sam bankman freed is
going to get life in prison and I
thought that that was an incredibly
interesting prediction uh you know
birdie Madoff got you know hundreds of
years
um there's this other uh Ponzi scheme
guy that I was reading about based out
of Texas who also got like 150 years and
so it's not crazy that that could happen
you know people who commit these
hundreds of millions and billions of
dollars Ponzi schemes they get life in
prison
[Music]
[__]
all right we are live Sean I'm in my uh
my official crypto hoodie what is that
this is fine oh yeah that's wonderful
perfect hoodie for today this is all
I've been wanting to talk about I
purposely haven't texted you about this
because this is all I want to talk about
but like maybe just give like a three to
five minute background on what's going
on I think you're the guy that should be
doing that and then I want to tell you
some of the more interesting points that
I think maybe haven't been covered or
are less covered that I think are either
hilarious or interesting okay great and
by the way should we check if my uh I
have a 25 000 withdrawal that's uh that
we will see we'll see if FTX has any
money left I'm gonna check right now and
see if it's come through
what do you think yes or no did I get my
25 grand out I think he I think you
probably got it I did it on November 9th
it's now November 14th it said it would
happen by today and it is
not in the bank account all right there
we go just another disappointment okay
so why don't I have my deposit uh
actually it's not even a deposit they
they advertise with us and so they paid
me inside fjx and I was just lazy and
never went through it
um
okay so basically what's happened here's
the what happened for those who aren't
following it that closely FTX which is a
big crypto exchange it's a place to go
to buy sell different cryptocurrencies
it was I think the number two or three
largest Exchange in the world used
mostly uh internationally
um
because it was kind of like uh you know
people all around the world want to buy
I think 90 plus percent of people buying
crypto are international
um
coinbase but bigger than coinbase bigger
than coinbase binance is number one I
think there's technically something
number two but really it's like binance
number one ftx2 and sort of like
coinbase and the others you know come
after that okay so FCX which was this
blue chip thing and it was seen as this
like you know Mega success story you
would see top investors
um in the world that were investing in
this so Sequoia uh which is like you
know a preeminent VC firm plus like you
know 50 others
um we're investing in this he's on the
cover of Fortune Magazine and it says
you know the next JP Morgan
um because he's you know this this this
young guy who becomes one of the
wealthiest men in crypto they say FTX at
its peak was worth about 32 billion
dollars and this company is only like
four years old right so it was had this
like crazy explosive growth and
valuation Sam was said to be worth 16
billion dollars himself he's this genius
traitor and um now entrepreneur he's
this crazy eccentric guy the guy looks
goofy as hell he's a uh he's a vegan who
doesn't wear shoes and gives away all of
his money if they're effective altruism
whatever you know he's got this sort of
character that everybody wants to talk
about which uh I bought into it very
easy to buy into you know this like you
crazy person who sleeps on the floor of
his desk and doesn't sleep on the bean
bag believe in normal stuff and he's at
29 or 30 worth north of 10 billion
dollars and he previously made a billion
plus by doing Arbitrage with like Korean
crypto so just some crazy [__] I bought
into it so that's the background we all
go on this this uh most people are on
that train of like okay I guess that's
what it is and then suddenly last week
there's a series of events we can go
into however much detail we want but
there's a series of events that
basically causes a bank run on FTX so
users lose confidence that FTX is
solvent which means they say I got to
get my money off 50x just as I did uh
you go you hit the withdrawal button
just in case there's any weird stuff
going on we've seen many things crashed
in 2022 in crypto uh Luna was one uh
Voyager Celsius there was a handful of
these things that crashed so people said
better safe than sorry let's start
withdrawing our money that creates a
solvent a liquidity crisis for FTX they
don't have the money to give and
everyone's like where the hell's the
money why don't you have the money uh
that's my deposit that's my funds you
know you go to the bank you expect them
to have your money and so FTX does not
have their money he comes out he says
everything is fine all the assets are
fine guys this is just you know a hoax
from a competitor there's a competitor
trying to F with us blah blah blah
binance is that competitor that he's
talking about
um so he's basically saying oh the big
the big the number one guys coming after
after us but we're fine guys don't don't
panic people still panic and in fact he
was lying turns out there's basically
this guy was a giant fraud uh you know
if you believe all the things that have
been coming out so allegedly we'll say
the word allegedly uh this guy was lying
deceiving everybody
um misusing customer funds et cetera et
cetera FTX goes under it goes from a 20
to 30 billion dollar company to a
company that is now declaring bankruptcy
billions of dollars there's like a 10
billion there's like 10 billion dollars
worth of customer funds that are gone
vaporized unaccounted for this guy's
fully in the country and you know all
kinds of crazy stuff so I'll just set
that as the background then now we can
go into whatever Parts you want to go
into all right so there's been a lot of
interesting things that have happened
and I want to name a few uh you know
there's the story's a week old now so a
lot of the the stuff has been covered on
the facts we can talk about the facts if
we want but I want to talk about like
some things that I think haven't been
covered first
the things happening on Twitter are
amazing this is all unraveling in real
time on Twitter one of the more
interesting and funny ones there's a
Twitter handle called autism Capital the
most based civil citizen journalism in
crypto we are currently following the
FTS Saga but please be patient we have
autism that's their
that's their uh that's our source of
Truth by the way that is who we are
reviewing on at times of trouble right
now but listen
it's hilarious and I think a lot of it's
right it's sort of like TMZ TMZ is like
considered trash because they sit
they're fast paced and they say a lot of
stuff that eventually every once in a
while they have to recant and say oh no
you know we got this wrong but you know
what they [__] nail it they called
Prince being dead or about to die they
called all this other stuff and that is
exactly what's happening there's so
there's all these interesting things
that autism capital is tweeting like SBF
that's this guy Sam uh the founder SBF
did a master class you know the company
masterclass on trading and it was set to
release in December and it's already
been filmed that's like an interesting
thing they tweeted another interesting
thing they tweeted is basically spf's
right-hand woman was this woman named
Caroline who rumors are that they also
were like sleeping together she ran the
hedge fund so the SPF owns all this
weird collusion she has a tumbler that
autism Capital found and uh it says she
had a post called the world optimization
where her Kink is men who control most
major world government
it's like people say always say oh I
want this but what I want is like a man
who's like control societies governments
things like that it's like what the hell
are you talking about
um yeah dude so I've I've followed them
like we I mean if you're in crypto you
follow these people you you know these
are con Sam was considered one of the
like you know more Blue Chip of course
there's always some people that are like
this guy's full of [__] or I don't trust
this guy or whatever but they're like
the the small small minority the
majority of people believed that FTX was
this fast growing company and that Sam
was this like really interesting really
smart founder
and then you knew the one part that was
always Shady so for example when they
advertise with us
they asked us to write a story on FTX
and we were like okay great we'll write
the story about how you guys grew so
fast what tactics you used why you know
why Grace have asked and we write the
story and then me and Ben were talking
we were like you know
stories all like you know perfectly Rosy
and that makes sense this is like a
sponsor like you know deep dive
basically
um but like you know we should put in
what are some of the concerns even if
nothing else just to like balance out
the story so that it's like not
literally just a Fluff piece so we were
like well what are some of the
criticisms and one was like
there well before he started FTX he
started this company called Alameda
research and that limited research not a
research company it was a trading
company that just called it research so
it sounded a little more serious but
basically and the rumors are like in
autism capital I think also shared this
they're like well Sam said he wanted to
call it Alameda research because that
just had an official sounding name and
he also didn't want people to know that
they were trading yeah and in the
entrepreneurial circles it was like oh
great little growth hack right you know
it's like when you said uh when we
wanted to get advertised for the hustle
I would first just write a fake ad for
some other company that I'd go to their
competitor and be like hey you're you
want this spot and like you know there's
a fake it till you make it that's
acceptable and then there's a fake it
till you're a fraud which is where this
guy like went totally wrong so so he had
this Trading Company hit the legend is
basically that
um at the time Bitcoin was trading at
let's say 10 grand in America but in
other countries where it was harder to
access Bitcoin there was a slight
premium people were willing to pay more
for a Bitcoin because it was so hard to
access because the government was you
know maybe not allowing exchanges to run
there properly or whatever so in Japan
and Korea everybody saw this Bitcoin
would be ten thousand here it'd be
eleven thousand or twelve thousand there
and so
um the legend of the origin story for
FTX is that Sam saw this he was one of
the people that exploited this Arbitrage
opportunity you know he basically
hustled went to Korea and um set up this
like Logistics chain where they could
buy a million dollars of Bitcoin here
sell it for a slight premium there wire
the money back and do it again the next
day just keep recycling the money and
that they made tons of money and nobody
really understood exactly how like there
was some plot holes in this but it was
like uh I don't know I guess these guys
are just smarter than us but like it's
like wait you made a billion dollars
doing this no that sounds a little
unreasonable so you might have made what
hundreds of millions but where did you
get the seed capital for this like you
weren't Rich so like how much initial
money went into this and there was never
like some clarity there so that was a
little bit strange but nobody really
what's the answer to that what's the
answer to that
they well now it appears the answer
might have been that that just never
even happened that might have been a
complete fabrication or they might have
done it at a much smaller scale
um nobody nobody still knows the answer
because this guy's like you know on the
run or you know hiding you know uh right
now so
so nobody knows the answer that but the
the bigger part the part that we wrote
about was like well Alameda research
um when FTX launched as an exchange
every exchange needs liquidity when
buyers and sellers come to the site they
need to be able to quickly get their
order filled so you usually have a
market maker or liquidity provider
basically who sits there and says I'll
I'll be the one who buys and sells
things and I'll take a small
um a small fee for providing that
liquidity to The Exchange so it runs
better so Alameda was the liquidity
Fighters the market maker for FTX and
um so everybody knew that and I was like
okay cool but it's like wait but Sam
owns both he owns The Exchange and he
owns the market maker isn't there some
conflict of interest so you know like
couldn't you know if this is a hedge
fund basically that can go buy things
but then FTX can list those coins
they'll know what they're gonna list
right so there's a little bit weird it's
a conflict of interest it's a little bit
of you know cousins kissing there and so
we had wrote about that we go you know
they have this kissing cousins thing
that people don't really like or nobody
knows the true extent to this
relationship between the two and they
were like hey we need you to take that
out and we were like well we don't
really think we should take it out we
think we're going to keep it in and they
were like okay cool like but just pause
this whole story The crypto markets
prices are going down we don't want to
be bragging about how well we're doing
right now so we were like okay you paid
us you don't want us to run the story
we'll never run the story so we never
ran it um but I remember at that time a
little it was a small red flag of like
I'm surprised that instead of clarifying
the relationship they're like don't talk
about that
so that was a little bit of a red flag
but you know like most things when you
have when you're reading nine out of ten
things are are just saying how this is
the Wonder kid and this is the best best
company and then you just have this one
little red flag you sort of brush it
aside at least that's what I did which
is a mistake by the way the the person
that you worked with there are they
still there
nobody's there dude the company's done
yeah but the person that you worked with
what do they list on their LinkedIn now
uh I I wasn't working directly with Mike
I don't know the guy's name um I they
saw you know Ben kind of was running the
milk Road really so I I was just kind of
like I would do the writing and then he
would talk to the guy or whatever so I
don't know the guy's name but um
anyways that was just like one small
thing and so what ended up happening
whether the sort of cause of this was
essentially that FTX was illegally and
um it was lying to customers and was
illegally taking customer money
giving it to Alameda through either a
loan or just like straight up funneling
the money there
um and then Alameda was going and
trading using the customer money trying
to turn a profit and was actually just
like kind of bad at trading it was
losing money
and so then they didn't have the money
to return
when all the customers wanted their
money out and um when they you know
quote unquote lent them the money the
collateral that they put up to take the
loan right like let's say users put in a
more like solid currency let's say like
Bitcoin
um Alameda borrows that Bitcoin to go
trade
and they put up in return as collateral
ftt token which is ftx's own internal
token that doesn't have like real that
much real value so when they lost all
the Bitcoin for it just for like to make
things simple here when they lost all
the Bitcoin all FTX had was the shitty
ftt token that wasn't that was worthless
so now there's no there's a huge hole
they lent basically 10 billion dollars
out and then couldn't return it and so
they went they went under and basically
now every day there's more leaks about
how crazy this situation was how these
guys were Liars how they were doing this
intentionally how they were doing drugs
how they were you know 15 people
sleeping together in this like Mega
Mansion while he pretended to be this
like big philanthropist and um maybe
he's an actor for the Chinese State who
know there's like crazy theories all
around and um you know nobody knows the
truth and this guy's coming out and
yesterday he tweets for the first time
and everyone's like oh my God here it
comes and he tweets out like a thread
and you know like you start a thread
with one and they used to say the first
point then you're gonna say two and then
the second point he treats out two one
and all he says is what
and then you see and then he does
nothing and then he tweets out two and
then the letter H
what does that mean and then just now an
hour ago he tweeted out a
and then 11 minutes ago p
ants maybe he's spelling he's like what
happened I don't know what he's trying
to do I don't know what's going on I
don't know maybe he's having a break or
something uh like I mean he might be
having a breakdown he might have been
dude I knew a guy who like was having a
breakdown uh and you know he had to be
institutionalized and he was tweeting
crazy [__] you know like and this is how
it started uh maybe the guy's going
through something like that there's this
there's another interesting thing that
happened with uh chamoth on the all-in
Pod he's and this is another thing that
I saw uh I think also autism Capital
they like clipped this clip and on the
all-in Pod shamath who has a whole bunch
of other questionable things happening
but he said something interesting where
he was uh looking at investing in FTX
and he was like you know it's kind of
weird how you guys are kind of
self-dealing I think you need a board
and I think you need rules around what
you can and can't not do with this and
he said the person working at FTX called
them back and literally said hey go [__]
yourself and just hung up and that was
the end of of the call
yeah by the way I think there's 70
chance that entire story is [__] uh
I think Shabbat is generally full of
[__] and uh you know so so I do not
believe this story for for what it's
worth
but dude have you seen the videos so the
woman name and I guess my point would be
if you knew that something effed up was
going on with this company the most
popular company in the in the world at
that time in crypto and that if you knew
that this was messed up like that there
was fraud going on or deception or any
of this stuff you would have said
something right like so maybe what he
said is I don't know I don't feel
comfortable with this uh but I feel like
he's trying to take some Victory lap of
being like no a new video in the clip I
believe chamat said he he I believe he
he put emphasis on this he goes he
literally said go [__] yourself no no
that part I believe I believe that they
would say that uh it's tomorrow's part
where he goes I called them they pitched
me I said this doesn't make much sense
but okay I'll have my guys look into it
and my guys looked into it we gave them
a recommendation you need government you
need to do this you need to do that you
and like they said go [__] yourself uh I
don't know something about that picture
being so white knighty uh uh you know
more red flags to be as well but a few
other interesting things uh basically
another Twitter thing these guys have
been doing these like Marathon Twitter
spaces uh one of the guys name is Mario
uh and he hosted this Twitter space
where Elon popped in and someone was
like Hey Elon what did you think when
you first met this guy SPF he goes well
people were telling me when I was buying
Twitter that he had lots of monies lots
of money but my [__] meter was
redlining and even all these major
investment Banks were like yeah this
guy's walking on water he's the best
he's got he has money and I just didn't
think that he had the money and I
actually believe this story to be true
and it just like it was interesting
because from an outside you think well
these billionaires all know each other
they know what's up and you know like uh
they they know if someone does or
doesn't have money they know does they
do or do not know if someone's legit and
elon's like I had no idea if he was
legit but he didn't seem legit to me but
everyone else said he was and I thought
that was like really interesting I was
like oh I thought this was like a club
where you had to like show financials to
get in inside of and turns out that's
not true and also the balls of SPF to be
buying stadiums uh to be hiring Tom
Brady and all these other like you know
Larry David these huge celebrities this
guy took this guy took a scam to the
next level you know so much hubris to be
tweeting or dming Elon and being like
hey I'm I'm down to put up 3 billion for
buying Twitter it's crazy so did you see
the text messages that leaked of that
yeah and uh what did Elon say he goes
they were talking directly so basically
the the text message that leaked it's on
uh this awesome Twitter handle called
internal Tech email so you can go check
it out there
um it's Michael Grime so I think is like
the head of it's like a banker I think
yeah yeah I think he's like one of the
top guys at Morgan Stanley so
uh what's his this is actually he's the
managing director at Morgan Stanley so
he texts Elon he goes hey do you have
five minutes for a meeting that I think
you'll want to take you know it's like
I'll call you in half an hour Minecraft
perfect he goes sandbankment freed is
why I'm calling he links to a a link of
fan Baker feed which is basically a link
to a story that like Sam Baker freed is
uh he was an effective altruist meaning
his goal was to make as much money as
possible so that he could give it away
that was the best way that he could help
and cause like positive change for
society was by maximizing how much money
you can make and then giving it away
which is like why there's all the memes
of like
you did it you took all her money and
you gave it away you know like wow
um
and so then Elon just replies two
question marks like what and he goes I'm
backlogged with a mountain of critical
work matters is this urgent he goes he
wants one to five billion serious about
partnering with you same security you
own not urgent unless you wanted him to
fly out tomorrow
um he goes he could do 5 billion if
everything is Vision lock
uh he would do engineering for the
social media blockchain integration
founded he founded FTX he believes in
your mission major Democratic donor he
was the number two largest Democratic
donor 40 50 million something like that
um because so I thought it was worth an
hour tomorrow he said he could shake
hands on five five billion if you like
him and I think you will
um can you talk with you know whatever
but it you know it could get us five
billion in equity in an hour he's like
trying to sell him like take this
meeting Elon replies blockchain Twitter
isn't possible as the bandwidth and
latency requirements you know basically
a blockchain Twitter won't work so this
doesn't make any sense and then it says
Elon disliked could do 5 billion if ever
if if uh if Vision lock would do so
engineering for social media blockchain
integration and then the maker goes got
it afford the equity interest to this
other guy instead but even if there's
not the blockchain piece he's interested
investing uh in Twitter and your mission
but we can we can put him on the
sideline for now 81 goes as long as I
don't have to have a laborious
blockchain debate
honestly one of the cooler things that
Elon has done or said in this entire
thing which is like all right I'll meet
the crypto bro just don't make me
[__] I don't want to get into an
hour-long talk about blockchains please
and um that I thought was hilarious
then he goes does Sam actually have
three billion liquid and then the guy
goes like yes I think Sam hasn't he
actually said up to 10 at one point but
in right he said up to five he's into
you and he said the blockchain's only if
you're interested is not going to push
it blah blah this other super rich guy
Orlando referred him and then he's like
uh we can push him to next week but I
believe you'll like him Ultra genius and
doer Builder like your formula built FTX
from scratch after MIT physics second to
Bloomberg and donations to Biden
campaign and so that's you know the the
Grimes what's this guy's name Mark
Grimes dude he's on the grind right now
you're fire bro you are fired we're
calling him Mark crimes instead of
Michael crash for whatever reason the um
we did this in the milk road we were
like you know it's just it's hard to
report bad news every day but it's like
hey bad news f-tex the biggest exchange
insolvent bad news wasn't even just a
miscalculation you know in good faith it
was actually fraud and deception we
think and that's what it looks like oh
bad news the money that they would have
otherwise had to pay out the remaining
customer deposits oh somebody just
hacked it last night and took six took
the last 600 million there's actually
zero in the bank accounts now so there
is nothing left for anybody uh because a
guy literally just did this and oh by
the way there's a plane going flying his
private jet is flying to Argentina
tonight uh we're tracking it here and
it's like dude this is horrible and
we're like What are we gonna do we're
like we're no longer calling this guy
SBF nicknames are for winners this guy
is now Samuel we're calling him his
government name and like Mr bankman no
not even no not he's Samuel uh from now
on
[Music]
where's the worst heavy
HubSpot is easy to adopt and actually
looks gorgeous I think I love our new
CRM our software is the best HubSpot
grow better
we uh I want to ask you about milk roads
engagement but first
um you tweeted something and I agree
with basically you're talking about like
it just like I lose trust in so many
things I'm losing so SPF or not FTX
owned I think 10 of Robin Hood which I
have money in uh not a huge sum I think
he personally uh him and Alameda owned
the the dude I'm gonna sell I'm gonna
I'm getting all my money out of Robin
Hood
I don't I don't trust anything I don't
trust any new startup that is in banking
I by default don't believe you whereas
before I would be like oh this is kind
of cool I guess like you have
MasterCards logo on there I guess you're
okay yeah I'm not team Innovation
anymore yeah no [__] that I'm going to
e-trades I'm getting my money off of uh
uh Robin Hood I to all the people who I
said oh you don't you know you just
don't get the disruptors I'm sorry you
are right I was wrong I'm sorry Daddy uh
you are you are absolutely right I do
not I I think I trust coinbase for some
reason because uh the guy Brian seemed a
little bit legitimate and they are
publicly traded so they do report
quarterly but uh I guess you gotta trust
somebody right like you gotta trust
something so for example I was like dude
I'm getting all my crypto off Robin Hood
At the minimum because I had way back I
had bought crypto on Robinhood and I was
like wait I can't just send it to
another wallet it's like no because
Robin Hood actually wasn't buying crypto
you're buying a crypto derivative I was
like what the [__] why did they say buy
Bitcoin like this is not Bitcoin this is
a Bitcoin tracking derivative it's not
even you don't even own the coins then
it was like okay now you could after
years it's like you could transfer it
off so I was like okay I'll get to that
when I get to it and um I bought a bunch
of eth on there and I was like uh I was
like me too I'm getting it all out of
there I go hit send it to eth wallet
it's like oh you've exceeded your five
thousand dollar maximum I was like five
thousand dollar Max every day you can
only do five thousand first of all why
um second of all that's [__] this
will take forever to get all my money
off this thing it's just like you had
another you know you had another strike
against you know Innovation I'm the old
guy on the lawn now shaking my fist
saying you know uh all you Rascals you
know stop playing with my money it's
like and it's not like it's not crypto
it's not like Bitcoin did anything it's
like the people building the companies
around this that are literally like
committing fraud or taking so much
Reckless risk that they're that their
their whole exchange goes insolvent
overnight or gets hacked that's insane
so I was like you know what I'm gonna
self-custody or you know take this
portion move it over here do this over
here you know I have this kind of
strategy I was like I'm gonna move more
into self-custody and um our buddy Greg
was like uh I was like what do you think
man should I should I do this or he's
like well I was like what do I trust
more myself or one of these exchanges
and he's like he's like uh you know and
I was like no I said what would feel
worse if I just lose my crypto or if
these guys lose my crypto he's like well
let me ask you a different question
how many airpods do you own and like how
many airpods have you lost he's like if
you can't keep your airpods you'll
really think for 10 years you're gonna
like not lose your crypto and I was like
Fair Point it sounds like you know okay
cycling through options of how to hold
this stuff so that hey I don't lose up a
b you know I'm not trusting anybody
luckily I wasn't really that affected by
FTX but like you know a lot of people
were and that's extremely you know sad
and disappointing and like those people
are you know they're traumatized right
that's like they got daddy issues now
they got trust issues they're they're
not coming back to the game and just
being like yeah I understand even if you
intellectually understand
that okay this guy was literally a
criminal right or like you know somebody
who was uh you know doing something that
was that was uh wrong misappropriating
user funds even if you acknowledge that
that was one bad actor it's like dude
there's a lot of Bad actors in crypto
and um how the hell am I supposed to
know it's not like you get to go sit and
audit the books of these companies it's
not like you get they say they say one
thing they do another like 24 hours
before it went in solvent the CEO comes
out and says all assets are fine we do
not lend out customer deposits 24 hours
later gone and turns out this guy was
lying well dude an interesting thing
about San Francisco and Silicon Valley
where we both kind of started our
careers is
it's all based on trust so there's like
a lot of times where you uh give people
money you just wire the money without
contracts you you pump people up and
make intros even though you don't
entirely you look at a slide deck and
you say okay this is what they're saying
the numbers are you don't say okay I
need your you know I need to go into
your database and I need to go check to
see this oh I need to check like I need
to check that this database number is
also not fudged by you know Bots or you
know faked downloads or whatever oh I
also need to check that your pixel is
not firing twice or you're not like
hiding costs over here with your shell
companies you don't know all that stuff
and it's a tremendous time to do that
this whole thing or our little world is
based on this type of trust and you and
I have both kind of got started right
when uh a great economy was was kicking
off and uh I basically didn't ever think
people were lying and that was
incredibly naive and now I feel even
though I haven't really been burnt by
this but I do feel I'm like oh I don't I
don't really try trust anyone anymore
and I think that everyone might be lying
just a little bit and it has changed my
perspective on that 100 and so I used to
see Robin Hood as like oh you're the
underdog like you're you know you're on
my side it's like Oh no you're you you
definitely can lose my money I I don't I
don't I don't believe you
um what about milk road so for the new
listeners milk Sean uh started this
thing called milk Road it's a daily
email for crypto with hundreds of
thousands of people is your engagement
skyrocketing or are people just telling
you to [__] off because they they hate
the whole industry
um no it's Abby this engagement's very
high because during a crisis a lot of
people want to read I think what we will
see though is over the coming months
that's not going to bode well for us
right like even if engagement's high
right now during you know the
play-by-play craziness of what's going
on right we're getting you know record
open rates and [__] like that you know
what happens three months from now as
people are just sort of disillusioned
the news is over the crisis is over it's
like you know
dude nobody's talking about Ukraine
right now the in my world like day to
day people aren't talking about Ukraine
every day I remember when that [__]
broke out it was like my mom my sister
everybody I knew was like glued to their
phone watching these videos [__]
getting zelinski tattoos and being like
Oh my God I can't believe this my heart
goes out thoughts and prayers blah blah
and then you're in day 98 and you're
like your thoughts and prayers go back
to like you know I I wish this whatever
you know just whatever your daily life
was you're like sort of revert you
stopped caring as much in the same way
like I think what's gonna happen for us
with the milk road is that engagement
spikes during this time but actually
it's not good for anybody in the
industry when somebody breaks like
customer and customer trust gets shaken
this badly that sets it back like
potentially years
um oh yeah I mean it's not a question is
is it set back by years it's is this
going to ruin it I mean like that's how
big this is in my in my mind yeah and I
think that one's probably not if it was
good like if crypto is gonna fail I
don't think it's going to fail because
of this like we've seen actually before
the number one exchange go down before
it's just like as the industry grows
disasters cost a lot more money and they
affect a lot more people but like we've
actually seen literally This Disaster
before with Mount Cox and there's a
Netflix documentary I've talked about on
the Pod about a Canadian exchange that
was literally doing this you would go in
it was like same thing guys bully genius
everybody loves them media loves him
starts this exchange becomes the biggest
one in Canada turns out there was
literally never anything in the deposits
like you would click buy big one you'd
send them the money you would never buy
Bitcoin he would just show the number in
your on your computer screen you yeah
you got ten and uh he would just take
the money go do whatever he wanted with
it and it was literally just like a
criminal he was lying and like anything
his own death then he mysteriously died
or Faked his own death and you know Sam
bakeries tweeting out one letter at a
time here is you know who knows what's
what's going on with this guy too so
like we've literally seen this exact
disaster before but it's higher profile
it's louder it affects more people and
now instead of losing Millions tens of
millions hundreds of millions now it's
billions that we're playing with that
that got lost here so I think it's
definitely bad but I don't think this is
like
the death blow to crypto I think if it's
like same thing with startups like
startups don't usually die due to
competition
that you don't get you don't die because
you got hunted you died because you
starved and I think if it happens if
crypto dies it's gonna be for the same
reason it's gonna die not because FTX
blew up and then people just all gave up
and you know decided I don't trust this
thing ever again forever and ever and
ever and everybody decided that it's
that really the the use case and the
utility wasn't strong enough to draw
people in continually over time
um and like maybe you know the use case
just wasn't big enough or it wasn't
strong enough there wasn't product
Market fit so I think startups and and
in this case crypto it'll die if it dies
of starvation not of competition you
know who's one of the big winners here
is Martin scorelli so basically Martin
shkreli Pharma Bro went to jail for a
couple years for scamming his farm
Pharmacy company or something like that
pharmaceutical company or something like
that you know Finance guy but very smart
I think a very smart guy and he has a
sub stack now that is incredibly
interesting and he's been doing Twitter
spaces where he's been like commenting
on this and he's like well you know
Jail's not that bad like you know like
he's saying all this funny stuff and he
wrote in his sub stack this morning that
he predicts that Sam bankman freed is
going to get life in prison and I
thought that that was an incredibly
interesting prediction uh you know
birdie Madoff got you know hundreds of
years
um there's this other uh Ponzi scheme
guy that I was reading about based out
of Texas who also got like 150 years and
so it's not crazy that that could happen
you know people who commit these
hundreds of millions and billions of
dollars Ponzi schemes they get life in
prison which is kind of crazy that you
can get life in prison for a non-violent
crime but uh his prediction is that he's
gonna go to prison forever so the Enron
guy Enron got 24 years as his sentence
uh let's see Bernie Madoff
well he Bernie died in prison you know
he got sentenced when he was in his 70s
but I think he got hundreds of 150 years
was like the you know the the headline
number uh and then I think the one
another big Ponte scene guy I think I
believe his last name was Samford Mark
Sanford I believe he uh at age 60
something got 150 years so he it's you
know regardless of when you get that 150
years it's a life sentence and so like
it doesn't believe it doesn't appear
that this is literally a Ponzi scheme a
Ponzi scheme Works in a specific way
like I think Madoff basically would like
he like had all the money in like one
checking account did you know this he
had like a million dollars in a Chase
account it was just like whenever
somebody requested he would pay him out
out of that and and you know show these
great returns or whatever but um in this
case basically the the effects the same
here you know like someone he defrauded
people into the tune of billions and
billions of dollars exactly and not only
that but uh the interest you know Bernie
Madoff I don't know if you notice know
this but do you know that he was the
head of the SEC for a minute of the
security exchange yeah he was that or it
was either that or NASDAQ I think I
think he was the head of the SEC and he
had and so he was like a big deal you
know and so uh so that was like you know
bold on his part but SPF did this in an
even Bolder way because he was
mainstream you know he owned or they
they had the naming rights to the Miami
Heat and they had commercials with Tom
Brady and so to me it's if I'm a judge
I'm like dude you're even you're rubbing
it in all of our faces this is more
egregious than Bernie Madoff who was a
little bit more quiet about it so you're
just like taunting me while you're
stealing so of course I'm gonna like get
you as hard as I possibly can
right yeah yeah it's it's bad I mean
it's very very visible very very painful
very like all day I mean just the the
gall of people I mean this guy is a real
[__] for what he did that's like
a crazy crazy thing to do and you know
there's like I could see one version of
it which is basically there's one
version of it which is
he
believed that this would like he wasn't
trying to steal people's money he was
like you know what like Alameda like
basically what people think is that
Alameda when Luna blew up uh Alameda
lost a bunch of money and in order to
save Alameda from having to like
liquidate everywhere
he's like okay let me just loan you this
money you will make it back because
you're good and then I'll like make it
all good in the end nobody no harm no
foul
um I know that I shouldn't do this he
didn't tell anybody about this that's
like one version of reality that could
exist there is some evidence against
that but like it's hard to know you know
we're talking about like autism Capital
as a source right I don't know if this
evidence is like anybody just like
making a screenshot or whatever you know
like it's hard to know at this point so
um you know so so basically there's one
version of reality that's that uh which
is he got stuck in a in a in a spot
where he was going to lose a bunch of
money and his thing was going to go
under and it was going to be very public
and bad and he tried to cover it up and
he kind of panicked and made a terrible
decision and he did something that was
wrong and illegal and um against terms
of service at least for for FTX and
but he he intended to like make it all
right and then there's another version
which was as of now that does not seem
like a very likely scenario
and what part makes you what what
evidence makes you say that uh like it
was like you you know that people were
saying that like he was he's allegedly
none of this has been proven that he's
been wiring himself for 500 million
dollars uh and that coincidentally the
FTX has been hacked uh things like that
like I I I don't I don't feel as though
that's that is going to be the outcome
yeah so let's say whatever there's some
probability that that that's what
happened and there's another probability
the more egregious possibility is like
basically he's like
screw everybody we're going to take the
money we're going to funnel it over here
I'm going to grease you know he lives in
the Bahamas he's like I'm gonna grease
all the politicians here I'm going to
grease the politicians of the United
States be the second biggest donor to
buy it in and I'm gonna you know go to
there's like this crazy stuff for like
his the girl who was running Alameda her
dad was like work with Gary Gensler and
who's like the SEC chair and like that's
why SPF and kensler kept meeting and
like we're about to pass this bill that
was gonna be very bad for D5 but very
good for FTX and it was like all this
like you know game to basically like
lock in this like money machine that he
was gonna you know continue to use for
his own benefit and Alameda was like
abusing the information that they had
front running the trades it's like the
like everything was evil and then
there's like the
slippery slope type of thing like if you
watch the theranos documentary for
example
um I shouldn't say documentary like you
know the theranos yeah the [__] movie
yeah whatever the show
um they make it look in that like what
actually happens is
she's wants to do something great she's
sort of delusional about her own
abilities thinks that I'm an
entrepreneur I could prove everybody
wrong thinks that the technology will
work things that she's buying time to
fake it till you make it to get it to
work and then at some point gets so
trapped in the lie that she just goes
all in on the lie because at that point
like her entire Image Ego company
Fortune is based on this working and
she's like
you know eventually starts just you know
actually lying and committing crimes and
so like that that became like but that
wasn't the intention day one I was like
I'm gonna do this scam I'm gonna scam
everybody and so I think that's the the
only question here but if regardless the
result is the same scam happened whether
he intended to do the scam from day one
or halfway through got into in a spot
panicked and it started to lie and
started to to commit these uh
um you know sort of I don't know if I
should call them crimes but you know do
what he did to add to the story do you
know who this kid's parents are
yeah they're like ethics teachers at
Stanford dude they teach of course they
are they're
perfect they're both professors of law
at Stanford law school I I think they
also like taught at Yale I mean so
they're supposed to be like no but they
also literally teach ethics yeah in
relation to to law from a legal
perspective I believe and they uh the
dad I think Joseph is the same he is
involved in FTX where he like helped
them raise some money so if this guy is
full-on lying Criminal
crazy man screw the I mean screwing
people out of money is is is bad also
screwing your family and your parents is
the worst right uh so like this whole
entire story you know it hurts a lot of
people but in terms of just like story
arc and soap opera it is just the best
it is the best
are you not entertained yeah if nothing
else is entertaining dude I don't even
like crypto you know I've I've been like
the crypto what is your prediction
saying let's put it on the record here
what is your prediction uh for crypto
not not FTX I mean it's pretty clear
what kind of we don't know the details
exactly what happened we know the result
for crypto what do you think is the uh
do you think this all just goes to zero
do you think this sort of Peters out for
a long time do you think this rises
again what is your prediction
I think and keep in mind my perspective
here is only emotional so and and
basically I learned from crypto just
from talking about you so everything
that I've learned about crypto it's been
live on this podcast so I would say I'm
not incredibly educated I think that
it's gonna Peter out for the next five
to ten years I think that nfts are gonna
go to zero I think that all the all
coins basically ethereum and Bitcoin are
the only ones that are gonna ever have
the chance of being interesting
virtually all of them go out of business
I think that um coinbase stays in
business and actually might grow because
people are like okay fine you're the
only place that I can trust uh I think
that uh like Luna and all this other
stuff and that one's already dead but
like all these other like other 100 go
to zero and never work and I think that
this guy gets sentenced to 25 to 50
years in prison
all right there's the prediction what do
you think
um I predict uh
Bad News Bears for the next
um
couple years is my guess
I don't know the time scale there but
I'm just going to guess a couple years
crypto winter I mean I think that's
probably true for the entire economy
right now but I think particularly worse
for crypto
um but I do think that in the end crypto
is real and is going to work
um and you know I know that's kind of so
but maybe now unpopular maybe it was
always unpopular I'm not sure I don't
really pay too much attention to that
but
um yeah I do think Bitcoin ethereum and
then Replacements to some of the other
use cases that that were built are going
to rise and I think some of the things
that are totally true I think this guy
goes down I think coinbase does well I
think that most of the current coins
that are completely overvalued go to
zero but I do think that Bitcoin and
ethereum are here to stay and I think
that they won't be the only two forever
I think there will be new ones that come
and do well
um in the future but I think it's uh I
also think it's another down cycle
anyone who raised money and they had the
word web3 in their deck I think
virtually 100 of them are gonna fail and
not work uh not necessarily because they
are bad entrepreneurs or because their
products are stupid although I do think
that is the case in the vast majority of
them uh I think that they're just gonna
be laughed out of like existence and
just like dude we're never working with
you like this is like consumers because
they're ugly which they are not because
they're dumb certainly so
but because you're gonna get laughed out
the room is that because they're ugly
it's not because they're dumb it's just
because they're pathetic
laughs
I think that's gonna happen
not all but but close to all yeah well
that's true I think for most startups
all right uh I gotta go visit my door to
keep knocking all right that's the pod
[Music]